la navette américaine discovery est
enfin parti la quatrième fois était la
bonne les ingénieurs de la nasa ont tué
24 heures pour régler les problèmes qui
se posaient au dernier né des camions de
l'espace laurent broomhead plusieurs
reports un faux départ et pour finir un
petit avion qui se promène nonchalamment
dans la zone interdite et discovery est
parti à 14h41 dès lors peu importe les
retards la navette n'ayant pas le
moindre droit à l'erreur le succès du
décollage n'a rien d'étonnant le
spectacle est magnifique l'engin fort
télégénique
mais l' angoisse commence maintenant
trois satellites de télécommunication
deux civils et un militaire attendent
que discovery les déposants nordiste or
discovery tourne à 2 196 km d'altitude
seulement pour monter jusqu'à trente-six
mille kilomètres
les satellites vont devoir utiliser un
moteur supplémentaire qui en février
dernier a déjà envoyé deux autres
satellites dans le décor le premiers
passagers payants l'ingénieur charles
walker sera lui certainement satisfait
du voyage car outre son expérience sur
un mystérieux médicaments la seule
publicité vaut bien les 700 mille francs
du ticket aller retour presque enfin
savoir si l'un des cinq com de l'espace
va tomber amoureux du 6e locataires du
dirait ce nick
mais cela c'est la petite histoire à
moins que cela ne devienne la grande